ce à quoi ça sert s'est pas jeté avant
d'expliquer je sais quelque chose qui
s'adapte à tous les autres systèmes
cohabitent avec la blessure
lundi c'est un entonnoir universel à
d'accord nous en fait partout en vain
ils s'adaptent
s'émerveille vendredi pour des envies
que tu as
fait exprès au point mais non fondée
je sais c'est que je suis pas très
surpris valoriser jacques tati 20
millions c'est quelqu'un très
raisonnable d'habitude bon dernière en
marché un jour
quand tu transvase un liquide d'un bidon
par exemple dans un autre bidonville du
toit
en général ça sa fuite en met plein
fouet non mais attends j'ai rien dit là
[Musique]